America's military is boosting its
efforts to help were Tory Co FEMA is
asking for military vehicles to clear
roads and bring in supplies the Coast
Guard says yesterday it delivered three
thousand meals and 4,500 liters of water
Omar Villafranca embedded with the Navy
and Marines on the USS Kearsarge one of
the ship providing support to Puerto
Rico
he's along the coast in San Juan Omar
good morning good morning the USS
Kearsarge dodged three major hurricanes
in the Caribbean to help the islands
recover from the storms dropping 180
Marines and vital supplies to those who
needed it the most the nerve center for
the military's humanitarian effort in
Puerto Rico is floating just a few miles
offshore sailors and Marines from the
USS Kearsarge were on the island the
morning after Maria hit Rear Admiral
Jeffery Hughes is in charge of the
mission what we want to do is make sure
that we can get large bulk commodities
and responders and relief supplies in
through those airports as well as
through Seaport
delivering vital supplies generators
food water even tarps so people can try
to get their lives back to normal but
getting back to normal won't be easy
during a flight over the northeastern
part of the island we got a first-hand
look at the damage and its extensive
from the air there were no relief crews
in sight petty officer 2nd class Rafael
Reyes is part of the relief effort but
this mission is harder for the Puerto
Rico native he hasn't heard from his
family in ayodhya
since the hurricane tore through the
town obviously I'm in the military so I
have to stay headstrong I have to stay
in the game
I do reflect on my family
there's no way that I couldn't but I
have faith boats planes and helicopters
are constantly coming and going from the
Kearsarge working nonstop as new
supplies come in we are prepared to be
here for as long as it takes to get the
job done it's a noble mission we're very
happy to be here
more help is coming by land and by sea
4,000 soldiers and Army Corps engineers
have already arrived in the US Virgin
Islands and Puerto Rico and the Navy is
sending their floating Hospital to
comfort which should arrive next week
gale can't get there too soon thank you
very much Omar Villafranca reporting
from San Juan